so look I can't think of the last time
the word World War 3 was trending on
Twitter one-and-a-half million times in
the 24 hour span after what happened
between Iran and us and everybody's
worried and they're messaging me
especially after the video I made back
in September I want to say that was
titled history of u.s. Iran conflict
explained which if you haven't watched
that you got to watch a today's video is
about recent events so in this video I'm
going to talk about the timeline from
April a 2019 to where we are today I'm
going to talk about who's soleimani is
that was killed then we talked about the
three reasons in war in the Middle East
the three main nations in involve
involved in Middle East who gets along
with who weighs Iran can retaliate where
US is weakened right now my final
thoughts about why this is a very unique
situation with the current president
u.s. has and the reputation Iran has and
what it can potentially lead to if we
don't make the right choices next
[Music]
so let's first go through the time on
that thing I want you to keep on mind is
that I'm not gonna cover everything
although I'm gonna leave the links for
you to go out there and do your research
but I'm gonna give you the main things
that took place leading up to the
killing of Soleimani we'll read today we
run in us April 8th 2019 Trump announced
the Islamic Revolutionary Guard corpse
IRGC as a terrorist organization you'll
know why this is important later on so
next June 28th US drone shot down by
Iranian forces u.s. claimed they were
flying on international airspace Iran
claims it was Iran's airspace so they
shot it down the next day on June 21st
Trump tweets he stopped last-minute
drone strike as retaliation Iran sees
this the following day on June 22nd Iran
said they would respond firmly to us if
US did anything on July 1st Iran exceeds
limit amounted of enriched uranium which
is what the most people are concerned
about around the world what if Iran has
nuclear warheads following on September
10th Bolton gets fired over Iran because
Trump was a little bit too concerned a
lot of people that know john bolton john
bolt really wants to go to war some even
call him a war monger so Trump fired him
next on September 14 this was a big
event
Ramco the bother just went public in
September two trillion and a half a
dollar company Aramco all attacks on
facility us says it was Iran Iran says
it wasn't us
who these which is a Yemen rebel group
took responsibility but pretty much
everybody around the world knows this
was Iran next on September 24 Trump asks
countries around the world to tighten
economic tension towards Iran at UN
General Assembly all nations have a duty
to act
no responsible government should
subsidize Iran's bloodlust this is very
interesting because at this time a month
after that I was at Monaco I went to
Cana and I spoke to a very strong
political figure at a Lebanon and he
says when this took place they had to
tighten all the banks all the businesses
with Iran this really hurt Iran's
economy but they were not feeling it yet
so let's fast-forward to November 15
watch what happens protesters in Iran
you remember this if you watch the news
they were furious because Iran all of a
sudden with no warning raise gas prices
by two to three hundred percent this led
to 631 people being killed that was told
by the opposition but Amnesty
International said it was around 300
Iran the United regardless that the
event took place next on December 11th
sanctions on Iran now included shipping
and airline industry which is obviously
getting tighter and tighter and tighter
with making money on December 27 two
days after Christmas a US contractor was
killed in Iraq by Hezbollah which is an
Iranian back militia and obviously this
infuriated a lot of people on Trump's
administration couple days later us
targets militia sites as a retaliation
for the attacks of the contractor that
they killed on New Year's Eve December
31st a pro Iranian paramilitary broke
into heavily fortified American Embassy
in Baghdad now obviously this is like
wait a minute are you wanting to push
the envelope you're pushing yourself
right now where US may retaliate
then comes New Year's Day then comes
January 2nd US Secretary of Defense mark
EPSA warns Iran may be planning attack
so everybody's like wait a minute what
do you mean Iran is planning attacks
this is January 2nd and this leads us to
the big event which is on January 3rd
okay u.s.
it has some Soleimani I Baghdad Airport
at 1:20 a.m. this is very important for
you to know what 1:20 a.m. means Iran
comes out and says there's gonna be a
harsh retaliation ok harsh retaliation
for what was done on January for Trump
tweets and threatens Iran that if they
do anything we will hit 52 cultural
sites of Iran which model he couldn't do
a couple days later he took that back
and said we couldn't do it because they
came back so you can't do that with you
and law when it comes down to where you
cannot have cultural sites but he did
make that threatened on January 4th
afterward January 5th Iraqi parliament
calls for expulsion of foreign troops
meaning a u.s. leave Iraq for many many
years we've been good allies we've been
ok with Iraq now you're telling us to
leave so Trump says if you want us to
leave we're gonna put the worst
sanctions worse than Iran on Iraq and
Iran kind of came back and said ok okay
just stay but listen stop kind of making
our life a little bit tougher than what
it is right now because Iran trying to
attack us January 6 rouhani tweets those
who refer to 52 should also remember the
number 290 never threatened the Iranian
nation in the TWiT he explains the 290
was the amount of civilians killed on an
airline that was shot down under the
Reagan administration back in the
eighties so he's reminding you talk
about fifty two we're gonna talk about
290 that's rouhani January 7th 56 people
were killed in the stampede or during
the ceremony during the funeral of
soleimani which they had to delay the
funeral actually changed some of the
times because of the 56 people that were
killed now Iran comes out this is very
important for the catches Iran comes out
and says on January 7th look we're
willing to work with you we're willing
to go peace and make this thing work and
u.s. is like okay Iran's willing to work
with us so after rouhani says that watch
what they do
remember the 1:20 a.m. at 1:20 a.m. on
January 8 Iran shoots 12 missiles and
hits Iraqi bases that houses US military
forces that's what they do then few
hours later Khamenei comes out and talks
to Iranians and says the following
last night we slap them in the face by
say and go home will you
Casa de garis only SC leadership in
addition this is a way of saying we
responded to what us did to us this is
the timeline we have so far what's
taking place with us in Iran so now
let's talk about who got some sort of
money is he as big as everybody makes
him out to be who is this man
Qasem Soleimani was born in religious
city of rome he was raised in Carmen
which Carmen is a very well-known for
politics that they teach and what Iran
stands for in traditions and by the way
the funeral was held in Claremont later
on reports indicate he joined the IRGC
hence remember IRGC what I told you
earlier on April 8th Trump announced the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard code he
joined the IRGC as a youth as a youth at
the beginning of the Iranian Revolution
in 1979 and played many roles until he
took over leadership of the Cootes force
in 1997 this is very important this was
announced eight and a half months later
he gets killed nine months later he gets
killed right so now let's continue IRGC
specializes an unconventional warfare
okay and military operations that
supports non-state actors these are
rebels militia rebels they're in many
countries such as Lebanese Hezbollah
Hamas Palestinian Islamic Jihad in Gaza
Strip or West Bank Yemeni Hootie's Shia
militias in Iraq Syria and Afghanistan
these are the rebels they support and he
is the voice behind all of these guys
supporting them with strategies of what
to do next and he is brilliant when it
comes down to being strategic he was
listed as a terrorist biting us they
categorize them as at that when he
passed away it was said that 82% of
Iranian supported him now part of this
could be propaganda because a lot of
times you know like there's a lot of
Trump supporters that will never say
they're Trump supporters until the day
comes to go vote but they will never
talk about it never say anything and
then BOOM 58 million people show up to
go out there and vote from whatever the
number is where did you show up I don't
know where you never talked about Trump
because they're afraid because they know
if you support Trump maybe the media is
gonna say stuff to them and out your job
you may lose something there were also
some people that opposed him but never
wanted to say anything these are the
people that voted to say we support him
82% he's a military genius took lead in
Iraq of Shia militia group he's seen as
potential next leader of Iran not just a
general military strategist the
commander of Special Forces he's not
just that he is seen as that I want to
remind you I did an interview with Sammy
the bull Gravano
he said something one thing he says
Patrick never worry about the person
that pulls the trigger always worry
about the person that's orchestrating in
the back behind the scenes and pulling
the strings of what to do next that is
solely money that's who he is
okay so now we have an idea of who was
killed he has killed a lot of Americans
he's killed a lot of Iranians and he is
hated and feared by a lot of people and
then there's a community that loves them
and here's why a lot of times we can
talk about it all from everybody's
perspective on how glad they are that
he's dead the other perspective is the
following you don't mind having a guy
like this on your side if that makes any
sense make sense so you know house
everybody has that one friend that
everybody fears you don't mind having
that guy with you because everyone fears
them he just don't want to be his enemy
and if he's your enemy you got to get
rid of him because he wasn't a supporter
of us and so us had to make that
decision they took the shots it is what
it is that this has even been made many
people are happy this took place some
are not happy to stick place now let's
continue let's talk about the three
reasons why there's always war and havoc
in the Middle East number one it's
religion what do you mean by religion
here's some basic things you got to know
about religion ninety-three percent of
the population in the Middle East
they're Muslims 93 percent or Muslims
right in the Middle East Christians 3.7
percent Jews 1.6 percent mostly in
Israel unaffiliated one percent and
Hindus around one percent I watched this
breakdown of Muslim this is interesting
to know what the breakdown of Muslim is
Muslim has two different denominations
if you want to put it right there's the
Sunnis and there's the Shias now the
Sunnis of the 93 percent of Muslims in
the Middle East 85 percent are Sunnis
15% are Shias in the world population
there's 1.6 billion Muslims worldwide of
the worldwide population 1.4 billion is
Sunnis 200 million is Shias just for you
to know this now how did the sunnis and
shias controversy start when
Prophet Muhammad died in 632 he had four
followers one of them was Abu Bakr which
was a good friend of his then it was
Umar Uthman and inures le which was a
son-in-law when that took place he
hadn't created a succession plan a lot
of people said he would have chosen Abu
Bakr as his successor because that was
his best friend and it was it was his
number one follower but a lot of people
said no it's gotta be somebody part of
his family
it's got to be Ali so at this moment
there was a division they voted and they
voted for abu bakr to be the leader and
the successor of prophet muhammad in the
muslim religion they became sunnis and
those who said shia ali they became
Shias that was a division right there to
keep that part amount you have to know
that Iran is mostly Shia 90 percent of
Iranian population the religious the
Muslims are Shias ten percent Sunnis and
Saudi Arabia is Sunni so keep that in
mind you have Iran is Shia Iraq is in
the middle and in Saudi is Sunni okay so
that's that part that you're looking at
now as we're looking at these things
this was religion point number two is
oil why oil obviously everyone knows
what's going on with oil there's two
numbers I want you to be thinking about
with oil one of them is supply how many
billions of barrels the top five biggest
suppliers of oil our number one is
Venezuela we've done a video on
Venezuela
that's a complete different story 300
billion barrels number to Saudi Arabia
267 number three is Canada 173 number
four is Iran 158 and number five is Iraq
153 out of the five top suppliers of oil
all live neighbouring each other think
about how big the world is three out of
five are right next to each other you
think there's a little bit of
controversy and conflict going on there
were competitiveness
now top producers of oil number one is
us it's roughly 15 million barrels a day
and this is a lot of the fracking that
we're doing in the Dakotas it's not
necessarily that we're bringing it in or
we're selling it we're pretty much using
everything that we need with the oil
because we need it it's not like we're
selling it to anybody else like some of
these other nations they make the money
off oil we don't we take it ourselves
Saudi Arabia's second 12 million barrels
a day then it's Russia
ten point eight million barrels a day
then it's Iraq four point four then it's
Iran
3.9 then it's China 3.9 the reason why I
put China here is four point I'll make
to you later on how this whole thing
could hurt China you'll see why in a
minute so you got religion you got oil
and the last one is nuclear warheads
let's talk about nuclear warheads watch
this leaders in nuclear warheads around
the world number one is Russia 6500
number two is u.s. 61850 the two
powerhouses by the way 90% of all
nuclear warheads are owned by two
countries you Russia and us that's what
90% of all roundel and there's only nine
nations that have nuclear warheads out
of all the countries that we have only
nine have nuclear warheads Russia's four
then US and France 300 channes 290 UK
215 Pakistan 150 India 140 Israel 90
North Korea 30 what nations do we talk
about
I didn't say Germany I didn't say Japan
not Iran not Saudi Arabia not South
Korea not United Arab Emirates not Italy
you mean to tell me Germany as big of an
empire that they had they didn't yes
because they signed a treaty that they
would because people were afraid
obviously would what happened with
Germany Japan had to do some of the
similar things after what happened with
us Iran is not trusted to a nuclear war
is because people are afraid what if
they do something they could cause havoc
here because the world is relying on the
supply of oil here the world wants this
place to be safe not just the Middle
East now let's continue so so far we
talked about the three reasons religion
oil and nuclear warheads let's talk
about these countries here this region
watch this they did a survey the other
day saying American voters can you show
on an unlabeled map where Iran is and
only 28 percent of voters could say
here's where Iran is most people don't
know the map not because you wake up in
the morning go study geography you just
have better things to do one lap don't
want to study this map which I
understand but which will go through it
here a little bit you got a Iran here
okay
the neighbor is Iraq to the left then
you have Saudi Arabia Syria Jordan
Lebanon and Israel is all the way on
this side okay so Saudi Arabia there's a
small country called Kuwait and then
down here you got Dubai Oman Yemen okay
so why is this so
and here's why it's important Iraq
essentially placed a wall between Iran
and Saudi Arabia this gives peace to
Saudi Arabia because it is a cushion
between them the stronger Iraq is the
better Saudi does the weaker Iraq is the
more Iran can use their militia from
here to come to Saudi and we'll get into
that here in a minute so to do that I
got an illustration here for you to give
you an idea of who gets along with who
in this region the Middle East ok I have
a hiss Bowl on a lot of different things
but I'm just gonna talk about three of
their countries here which is what Saudi
Arabia Iran and Iraq let's take a look
at that so if you look at Iran Iran gets
along with Iraq doesn't get along with
Israel and doesn't get along with Saudi
Arabia
that should tell you the whole thing
pretty much and if you look at Saudi
they don't get along with Iran or Iraq
especially today on what's going on
because Iran and Iraq have kind of
joined forces a little bit today right
on what's taking place so what does all
of this mean let me bring you over here
on the three countries Iran Saudi and
Iraq okay
Iran's population is 81 million people
okay their size land wise it's six
hundred thirty six thousand square miles
that's Iran Saudi is only thirty three
million population but they're eight
hundred and thirty thousand square miles
okay and then Iraq is only thirty eight
million but it only has a hundred and
sixty eight thousand square miles now
watch this if you combine a population
of Iraq and Saudi Arabia together it's
still smaller than Iran and if you
combine the size of land between Iran
and Iraq it's still smaller than Saudi
Arabia so the reason between this
conflict between Iran and Saudi is
because years ago Saudi Arabia was just
part of the Ottoman Empire and when the
Ottoman Empire took over Iraq and and
there were some conflicts these guys had
a little bit of momentum they won their
land and they won this land over and
they named it Saudi Arabia 1932
okay so 1932 is the only timeline that
Saturday has been around that's only an
88 year old country it hasn't been
around for as long as Iran's been around
so up until this point Iran was a
superpower oil all of these things that
they had they were still having a lot of
conflict because Britain Britain and
Russia took over twice and they were
kind of going back with their oil but
nobody was looking at Saudi Arabia six
years later they strike oil and they
realize they have more oil than anybody
else
the world at the time until they
realized Venezuela's number one but at
the time it was Saudi Arabia has more
oil than North America Central and South
America combined everybody looked at
Saudi Arabia as the superpower now Iran
is not happy about it because Saudi is
getting detention so now there's
competition there's the reason why I Rex
playing a big role right so watch what
happens next
now there's a dispute iran says persian
gulf saudi arabia calls it arabian gulf
matter fact there was a time when
Michael Wallace and he says you can tell
that you hey what are you doing calling
it Arabia you went to school right what
did they call you when you went to
school and Mike Wallace can't even
answer this the Persian Gulf I don't
care what they want to call it they can
call it whatever they want there's
already a little bit of competitiveness
going there right so now this takes
place how do they fight worse because
Iran and Saudi Arabia have never had a
direct fight before but there's two
different ways to have war one is a cold
war which is pretty much everything
except killing somebody anything except
we're going to war meaning threats
propaganda rumors anything you do
internal division cold war that can go
on for a long time it happened obviously
between US and Russia for very very long
time but a form of war that they can go
to Cold War the other one is a proxy war
what a proxy war is when you use another
nation to instigate them going against
you so for instance when Iraq is going
against Iran when Saddam Hussein was
running the nation Saudi Arabia is
helping Iraq to go against Iran because
that's a proxy war and when some of the
militia is going against Saudi they Iran
support the militia to go against
whoever it is that they're going up
against right they support would militia
that's what you call a proxy war so
they've been going back and forth for a
while and this is all leading to the
following the current situation Iran
lost their number one
general Iran was got some Soleimani Iran
lost the person that was supposed to be
the future leader of Iran Iran's regime
Khamenei rule law these guys are excited
that this man is a strategist brain he's
gonna one day run Iran with our
philosophies would our belief system
with the things we believe in the Shia
how many was a shot he's gonna go follow
this all we are building the skies the
future they lose them think about if you
lose your number-one guy okay what
happens weighs Iran can retaliate here's
I Iran can retaliate a lot of people say
cyberattack it's on the list because
Iran has some of the best hackers but
it's not number one on my list number
one on my list is the following the
jugular of global economy called the
Strait of Hormuz and here's what it is
right here okay you see right here
between ironic Iraq and Iran and Saudi
right here is what's called the Strait
of Hormuz now why is this so important
why is it called the you know the
jugular of global economy here's why
dozens of oil tankers passed through
this daily carrying upwards of 84
million gallons of oil dozens a day each
carrying 84 million gallons of oil 20%
of world supply global economy full 20%
of the flow of global supply goes
through right here
20% one out of five is right here Strait
of Hormuz okay 76 percent of the crude
oil that moved through the choke point
went to Asian market let me say this
again 76 percent keep this month
remember how I said China has oil supply
daily of three point nine million
barrels a day that a day that's not a
lot they rely on this here so if
something happens here a lot of the
Asian market could take a hit so they
have to be very careful if Iran really
wanted to get ugly they would do it
right here that would hurt the world
economy with oil now let me continue
cybertek was one of them more proxy wars
more propagandas another possibility of
a 911 that could take place but I don't
think that's the worst case let me
consider what I think could take place
here's us as weakness this is where we
are weak as a country where US is weak
number one we
are so divided it's unbelievable it's
almost as if the Democrats and the
Republicans the Democrats would be okay
for a war to start as long as Trump is
out of the office that that's almost
where we are politically think about
that for a second
there is such a major division that
anything to get Trump out is a priority
not the protection of the states this is
very very ugly it's like when parents go
at it hardcore and it's all about mom
getting something from dad you know all
this stuff that's taking place and they
forget the kids are taking and paying
the biggest price that's what's going on
with our politics so what happens here
yeah he should have came and told
Congress that they're gonna take our
soli money if he would have told
Congress Congress would have leaked that
there's no way he would have left the
airport they would have never had a shot
to kill insult solely money so if the
intention was to kill solely money they
did the right thing okay if they would
have told Congress the way our setup is
something with a leak that would have
happened he would have left it we would
have lost the opportunity of doing that
next election is here and during
election Democrats and mainstream media
is gonna go hard core like never before
and the more they do the more data
they're given to who to Iran and Iran
shows and says look at us they're so
divided look at us we're so United look
at them they're so divided this is what
could be taking place right now because
US is weak so look my final thoughts
here here's what I want you to be
thinking about obviously when you look
at the whole timeline Soleimani three
reasons you know the conditions here
between these three nations and then who
has retaliation methods of Iran what US
has weaknesses are the last thing I want
you to be thinking about is the
following obviously if we play the game
of chess Iran took out a contractor
which many people may say that's a pawn
on a chess sport obviously it's a life
it's somebody's family that was lost but
in the game of war it's upon Iran lost
in a game of chess board take the King
out that's raw law Khamenei any of those
guys you took those out Iran lost a
queen that's general Soleimani so it's
not like it's pond for pawn or Queen for
Queen no no it's a pond for Queen and
Iran doesn't forget this that's why
iran's Foreign Minister said Iran is a
very
patient nation well I mean that Iran is
a very patient country we will take our
action after necessary deliberation but
I'm sure that it will be taken at the
time of our choosing
by the time of the United States Jersey
before they made the attacks is he
talking patient like hey we send the 12
missiles I don't think so
I think the 12 missiles were simply to
save face in front Iranian people I
don't think it was retaliation and I
think they knew that nobody was going to
get killed
here's what I think they knew nobody was
going to get killed because the current
administration in u.s. is ran by a man
who is very proud think about it this
way who in the history of US has had a
bigger ego than president Donald Trump
who actually think about who is more
proud of his accomplishments who is
anybody can you think of anybody you've
if you actually think about it
maybe Lyndon Johnson I don't know proud
maybe Nix who would you put as a proud
maybe JFK I don't know who do you put as
a proud like let me tell you what I've
done brocco bomb so proud of what I've
done right some may say he's at the top
and what happens with people that are
very proud of their accomplishments
whether you put a Brady Kobe Jordan any
of these guys that were the best of the
best in their eyes what what do you not
do to them
you don't publicly humiliate somebody
with an ego and if you do they are
willing to go to measures that maybe
others not willing to go to and I think
Iran knows that that's why I didn't
retaliate but they just kind of shut the
12 missiles to places that didn't kill
anybody
I think they knew that but I also think
the Foreign Minister says your honor
Iran is you're a patient nation which
means we got time we're gonna do it on
our terms
6 months 12 months 24 months post Trump
being gone
maybe when Jimmy Carter was presidency
Iran had the 52 hostages when Reagan was
getting elected that day here's your 52
hostages back because Reagan said we're
gonna retaliate and get those people
back and Iran knew they would retaliate
and they don't want to go to war would
Reagan maybe they don't want to go to
war with Trump but maybe they will go to
war with the next president I don't know
maybe it's gonna be a Democratic
president that doesn't want to go to war
with them and they'll say here's an
opportunity will retaliate
and will say remember 290 remember what
you did to Soleimani here's what it is
we have to make up for it and
somebody else and let it kind of slide
there not somebody that's gonna forget
about this no way they're gonna forget
about this just listen to what his
daughter said and what a lot of the
leaders said they're not gonna forget
about this now
having said that in us there is one
thing that hasn't happened in this
entire conflict neither us nor Iran has
touched the other nations soil meaning
us hasn't done anything to Iran soil
Iran hasn't done anything to us soil us
has taken out their number one general
Iran took out a contractor right nothing
so if Iran was to do something to US
soil during Trump administration how far
do you think Trump would go actually
answer the question
you I'm not answering it for you think
about talk about it with your peers
comment below how far you think Trump
would go
you think there's limits to him and I
think they know that that he may go
places that were as bad as some of the
wars in the past that if you remember
Japan he can go places that maybe others
don't want to go to because he's got
control at the top as a precedent this
is gonna be bad for everybody around the
world and I think both know it and I
don't think neither wants to go to war I
don't think they want to go right now
and I don't think US wants to go right
now let me tell you why Iran definitely
doesn't want to go right now because the
current conditions in Iran remind me of
what happened in 1978 77 Carter comes
toast to Shah leaves revolution begins
the next day 13 months later Shahs out
exile leaves Iran goes to Khomeini
mi6 US CIA they bring him in this has
already been reported written about
people knew how many was going to come
in and they help them and how many
becomes comes to Iran takes over and
then boom all these other guys show up
if the current regime coming in and
Khamenei and the rest don't want to see
Iran go through another revolution if
they don't figure out a way to become
better with us and they keep playing
these games they may lose their people
and if they lose their people and
there's a coup Iranian people is in
their blood they know how to do a coup
if they wanted to do could they could do
a cool this is probably the best time to
do a coup if you're Iranian people
wanting to see the revolution change
go back to more of a friendly
environment where somebody like me can
go on vacay go for a vacation in Iran
and other people like back in the days
when Elizabeth Taylor was dating Zahedi
and you know all these singers and
performers Dean Martin Frank Sinatra
would go to Iran and perform and we
could go was a beautiful place on the
70s you know all this vacation rich
people would go to Iran great places to
go to there are many people that would
like to go back to those days have
covered Tehran days but the current
regime doesn't want it to go there and
they know it if they push a little too
hard the Iranian people have a good
memory and they know what to do and this
time around it might get very ugly
because if you touch my pocket as a
populist I can't feed my kids I can pay
my rent I'm in shambles what fights
because you want to make up the money of
your loss with the sanctions of Iran by
raising the price of gas with me I may
retaliate to you and we the people
historically as always won and if that
happens who things could get very very
ugly very very ugly if that happens so
again these are my thoughts my opinions
I'd love to hear from your thoughts
below if you didn't watch the first
video I did that prompted this video it
was titled history of u.s. Iran conflict
explained click over here to watch it
would love to hear your thoughts below
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]